hello everyone and welcome to a video
where i will be playing uh
a chess game against the maya chess uh
and uh maya is a human like neural
network chess
engine uh that plays uh like an engine
uh
she probably can be strong as a regular
engine like leela
zero but she uh tries to make moves that
are more human-like so
in order to give you a better idea of
what's uh what's all this about
uh i will just uh show you uh from their
website a few sentences so
you get a better idea so my chest is a
human-like neural network chess engine
now we already said that and here it is
uh capturing human style in chess
so here you can see a graph with a move
matching accuracy uh between stockfish
leela chess zero and the maya chess
stockfish you can see a little bit below
40 40 percent
matching human moves lila is uh well
somewhere around 44 i would say
and maya is well over 50 in matching
human moves so they say
maya's goal is to play the human move
not necessarily the best move as a
result maya has a more human-like style
than previous engines matching moves
played by human players in online online
games
over 50 percent of the time and
they say that maya is an alpha zero lila
like deep learning framework
that learns from online human games
instead of self-play
so when leela chaziro was learning how
to play chess
uh she played uh i don't know how many
millions of games against herself and
then
became very strong whereas maya learns
uh from online human games uh instead of
cell play
maya is trained on millions of games and
tries to predict the human move
played in each position scene we trained
nine versions of maya
one for each elo milestone between 1100
and 1900
maya 1100 was only trained on games
between 1100 rated players
and so on each version learned from 12
million human games and
learns how chess is typically played at
its specific level
so there you have it uh we measure move
matching accuracy how often maya
predicts a move uh
is the same as the human move played in
the real online games
because we train nine different versions
of maya each at a targeted skill level
we can
begin to algorithmically capture what
kinds of mistakes players at specific
skill level make
and when people stop making them so here
we have an example
uh the mayas predict that people stop
playing the tempting uh
but wrong move b6 at around 1500 so here
uh is an interesting position and uh if
white pushes the pawn to b6 black will
capture
uh with the queen uh black will capture
the c5 pawn with the queen
and uh his uh well white's position will
just uh
be messed up white's gonna lose all of
its advantage so
it uh could be very useful if you were
training for a very specific opponent
and uh well you had a maya for example
to prepare you for that specific
opponent
uh for example mike would go over all of
his or hers games and then tell you
which mistakes he he or her most usually
makes
and i'm not gonna read everything from
the website as there are quite a lot of
interesting things here so you can go
over it yourself uh but
basically you can also play against maya
you can plug and smile yourself on
leeches you can play against maya 1100
1500 and maya 1900 i wanted to make a
video where i will
uh play a game against all of them but
after finishing a game against my 1100
uh i could no longer get a game uh they
had
some sort of a malfunction here they i
even asked them on twitter
they said that uh it was uh uh well it
was a
a problem uh because uh sorry let me
just uh
let me just bring that up uh they said
sorry about that uh even though i
haven't adjusted any volume in this
video and
not said sorry about that they said
sorry about that so it seems like we
can't make a video without sorry about
that
but all the all the interest has them
down at the moment we will ping you when
they're back up they did not ping me uh
as of yet
so i decided to make a video based on
one game alone
and then if you guys are interested we
can check out the other mayas as well
so in short maya is an ongoing research
project using
chess as a case study for how to design
better human ai interactions
we hope maya becomes a useful learning
tool and is fun to play against our
research goals include personalizing
maya to individual players
characterizing the kinds of mistakes
they are made at each rating level
running maya on your own games and
spotting repeated predictable mistakes
and more
this is work in progress and we would
love to hear what you think please
let us know if you have any feedback or
questions by email or twitter
and here we have uh well some other very
interesting information and
this is the theme behind the project so
you can check that out as well there you
go
let me just uh frame that nicely uh
there we go team all right
so that's it with the introduction uh
and then uh after reading all of that
and
figuring out what maya actually was uh i
decided to play a game so this is a game
against maya 1100
and let me tell you she's much stronger
than 1100 i don't know what they were
what they were doing but uh that's not
1100 play
uh so i have the black pieces in this
game and uh it's a three minute blitz
game
so i didn't want to play a longer game
and i just wanted to get at least one
game in
uh so let's just check it out maya has
the white pieces and opens with
d4 and uh to see uh what kind of an
engine it is
i played e5 i went for the the england
gambit
uh maya accepted the gambit and i played
f6 so i want to give up another pawn to
get some rapid development
and grabbing this pawn is not the the
best way to play this position
and there are much better moves e4 or
knight f3 and stronger players will
often
uh play this but uh for bullet and blitz
games i enjoy playing this
very much as pretty much no one knows
the theory uh behind it so everyone will
will make a mistake uh but unless you
get to a higher rating and then you know
no one will fall for it
so e captures uh maya captures it i
recapture knight captures on f6 and
knight f3
and here bishop to c5 and here i'm
uh white of course is better white
grabbed the pawn and uh
i mean uh black is up a little bit in
development but it's not enough to
uh for the gamete pawn and here is a
very interesting position because i
can't tell you how many bullet games i
won
for example if white goes bishop g5 i
sometimes go 94 i mean not sometimes i
always go
94 in this position and the white thinks
you blunder the queen but after
the queen is captured just bishop
captures and have to use checkmate
and you know you're going to be very
happy by winning a game like this
however maya doesn't go for something
like that knight the c3 is played and
here there is one game in the database
where d5 was played i
played knight to c6 and it is already as
of move 5 that we have a completely new
game
so here maya continues with e4 and i
castle the safety
uh and here bishop to c for check i go
king to h8 and now maya also castles the
safety
and here i play d6 and i'm down upon but
my position isn't isn't all that bad so
bishop to g5 developing with a pin and
here i go
bishop to g4 the same with h3
challenging my bishop and bishop to h5
and here maya bravely and boldly goes g4
so challenging my bishop and i just
retreated with bishop to g6
here you could play some other moves
like you could consider
now well you can't consider sacrificing
because the the knight is pinned
but there are ideas like queen uh to d7
or queen to c8 to allow the capture of
this bishop and then maybe you can go
down to h3 with the bishop here slicing
over
could be very dangerous but uh in the
mindset of playing against an engine i
just retreated the bishop
and now comes knight to d5 uh i played
queen to e8 uh here
uh i i want to un-pin uh but i also
decided to uh to allow the capture of
the c7 pawn which is weird but
uh uh again i'm in the mindset of
playing against an 1100
opponent and i don't really mind playing
any move uh for that matter but
capturing an e4
is the way to go here because there will
be a lot of pressure on the f3 knight
so here i played queen to e8 it's a
pretty bad move
and of course knight captures on c7
follow so the queen is under attack rook
is under attack
uh i move back queen to d7 and now
knight captures and here i recapture the
knight
again uh sacrificing on g4 was a little
bit better than recapturing
there's always time for this this is uh
definitely the way to go
yeah but i played the normal recapture
and here we have bishop characters we
have g captures and
now knight the h4 and here white is
completely winning
so uh i'm completely trashed in 16 moves
so
that's very nicely played by by an 1100
opponent
uh we have bishop captures on e4 i
grabbed that pawn
uh and now comes rook to e1 and here
uh i still uh i'm still trying uh i do
have a very nice bishop pair i always
enjoy a very nice bishop there and if i
can somehow mobilize my pieces maybe i
can still try something here
so i played rook to e8 here defending
this bishop and now comes
knight to f5 and it's just again a very
very tough position for me to play
a terrible one at that uh so i decided
to eliminate the knight
bishop captures g captures uh and now
comes queen to g7 with
check uh maya just moved the king king
to f1
and here i played knight to e5 avoiding
a trade uh i want to
try and get this rook into the game but
it's very hard however
maya makes it easy for me and she allows
me one move
that actually allows me to win the game
here maya played bishop to b5 as i'm
attacking the bishop
but um it's uh it's not the way to go
here the the best reply for white is to
either move the bishop or to play queen
h5
or for a bishop but attack sorry uh
attack the rook here so this is one of
the moves that are possible however
here maya played bishop to b5 gave me an
opportunity and i immediately went for
it and now there's one move that wins
the game for black
and uh well feel free to pause the video
and find that move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the only move that wins after playing a
terrible game with black
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to g8 this is
what i played and
i was very happy to get this little
glimpse of hope
uh ma started running away with the king
and here i just played queen to g2
threatened the df2
pawn and here comes uh the the most
interesting part of the game at least
for me
here maya played rook to g1 attacked my
queen
uh and well what follows was just uh
queen captures an f2 checkmate now you
might wonder
wow i mean okay it's a it's an engine
but why would an engine allow mate in
one
i think what happened here is that if
you do something like king to d2 i can
still just capture and after king to c1
uh now a lot of things win for example
if knight f3 going after the rook rook
f1 just bishop to e3 with
check and here just let's say an id to
check completely wins the game
but i think what maya did here with rook
to g1 uh probably
uh hoped that i would miss queen
captures an f2
uh and if i go back for example queenie
for check king to f1 and the white is
defending all of a sudden i i don't have
an attack anymore
so this is uh this is what i think that
happened here and it was a very sneaky
idea but luckily i was able to do it
uh so after this rook to g1 i just
played queen captures on f2 with
checkmate
i will put a link to the game uh it was
played unleasher so you can check it out
and go through all the moves if you want
to
but what's uh what's very interesting
about this game is that
it's a three minute game i spent one
minute on the game i think one
minute and one second whereas maya spent
only two seconds
on this entire game so out of the three
minutes uh she was left with two minutes
and 58 seconds on the clock
so very very uh commendable
but yeah i only managed to get a gaming
against my 1100
when i get a game against maya 1900 i
will
uh try to play a bit more solidly and
don't go for any
sneaky openings but for this one i
was very very amazed that i actually won
this game because
if not for this bishop to b5 move in
this position which uh
completely dominating uh for white the
bishop is needed here guarding the g8
square you cannot allow rook g8 but
after this i mean i i i was
uh probably as surprised as you guys are
now that i actually won this game so
pretty
pretty crazy stuff so i will put a links
to all of the my so you can challenge
them in the description below also
i'll put a link to the matches website
so you can read more about uh
about it as we didn't go through all of
it so i do hope you guys enjoy that as
well
and uh yeah uh the challenge maya see
how you
fare against her and uh maybe you you
will also face some very interesting
moves like uh
like rook the g1 here allowing me this
mate in one which is
i i i don't i mean even if you play
against the weakest engine even the
weakest engine will not allow you a mate
in one
the engine will always try to survive
for at least
two or three more moves depending on the
position but here allowing this i think
maya actually
uh was hoping for a blunder for me and
then then she could survive
so very interesting stuff uh and yeah uh
that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it ended a little bit of uh
well uh not history but general
knowledge about
what maya chess is uh so play against
her and uh
see what happens it's it's a it's a very
interesting project
uh so once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would i would like to
thank ben lutet
uh joseph striver uh hoodie guy aras
bacho and then
dean wrigley for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
i'm very eager to see
where this project goes see you soon